alors belletti bonjour merci être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors finalement à quoi sert cette
primaire populaire c'est l'e3 tête
d'affiche yannick jadot jean luc
mélenchon ou encore anne hidalgo don
décidé de lui tourner le dos ils seront
candidats à la présidentielle quel que
soit le résultat
la difficulté de cet exercice c'est un
peu le triangle des bermudes de lignon
et de l'efficacité parce que l'objectif
de cette primaire c'est de créer les
conditions
initialement de l'union de la gauche du
rassemblement et afin d'être plus
efficace électoralement et de porter un
projet de gauche qui soit susceptible de
l'emporter à l'élection présidentielle
or à ce stade ce que l'on constate c'est
que les principaux jours les
représentants
qui sont en lice pour cette élection
présidentielle qu'il s'agisse de jean
luc mélenchon à côté de yannick jadot de
l'autre le monsieur roussel également
dès aujourd'hui de madame hidalgo aucun
de ces candidats souhaitent être
associés à cette primaire dont déjà il
ya quelques pains blancs vrai 122 morts
l'espoir des initiateurs de cette
opération c'est de pouvoir vaut
bénéficié d'un élan qui se donnait au
candidat ou à la candidate qui sortirait
en tête de cette consultation populaire
la réalité c'est que on est aujourd'hui
face à deux problèmes d'abord la
désunion structurelle de la gorge qui
ramène les th2 la gauche aujourd'hui on
est en termes d'intentions de vote
est-ce qu historiquement bas qui fait
mieux à peu près de l'élection
présidentielle de 1969 et que le parti
communiste d'un côté le parti social de
l'autre avait à peine atteint 3% je ne
suis même pas sûr qu'au niveau de
l'intention doit-on toujours bien cet
étiage là et ensuite le deuxième sujet
c'est que l'on est quand même
la fin janvier en fin janvier c'est à
dire qu'il va être aujourd'hui trois
mois trois mois pour s'organiser trois
mois pour créer les conditions d'une
dynamique en effet c'est
justement celle qui est favorite
à cette consultation citoyenne c'est
l'ancien ministre de la justice à
christiane taubira qui espère créer
cette dynamique dont on vous parlait en
cas de victoire est-elle crédible selon
vous
il est clair que si vous voulez madame
taubira dispose d'un capital politique
qui est lié à son parcours personnel à
gauche et qui peut en effet et plaire
une partie de l'électorat de gauche elle
a un charisme qui fait que c'est une
personnalité qui est tapé une
personnalité cloniques mais ça ne suffit
pas ça ne suffit pas à ce que si vous
voulez le contexte politique aujourd'hui
c'est que la gauche est en désaccord sur
le leadership c'est à dire sur le choix
de son leader la gauche est en désaccord
sur un certain nombre de sujets qui sont
des sujets disons absolument essentiel
en termes de positionnement je pense à
la culture
la vision de la république on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui il y a des gosses
qu'on appelle les gauches
irréconciliables entre une gauche plutôt
social démocrate qui a une vision de la
république est une vision de
respectueuses des principes qui sont les
principes de la laïcité par exemple et
d'autres il serait plus une loge
d'accommodement donc temps que tous ces
sujets ne faut pas tranché on voit mal
comment une candidature y compris la
candidature de madame taubira a porté
par une primaire populaire pourrait
résoudre comparé miracle l'ensemble de
ces sujets qui sont qu'un des sujets
encore une fois extrêmement lourd est
extrêmement complexe alors bon après
espérer qu'il y ait un roulement
technique comme on dit en bourse
certaine manière parce que madame
taubira et seraient désignés comment
démontrer d'ailleurs par la mairie
puller peut-être aujourd'hui madame
taubira dans les intentions de vote je
fais à peu près jeu égal voire et
d'étiage supérieur en 2010 d'algos mais
entre 3 4% pour démarrer
suffisant et dynamique alors je voudrais
revenir également à jean luc mélenchon
qui a déclaré que cette primaire a qu un
objectif nuire à la france insoumise
peut-elle vraiment lui porter préjudice
je ne sais pas si la primaire va lui à
la la la france est soumise ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'à ce stade en tout cas là
aussi au regard des sondages disons que
jean luc mélenchon est celui qui est le
mieux placé pour arriver en tête à
gauche il est entre 9 et 10% ce l'espoir
de jean luc mélenchon c'est se retrouver
dans la situation de faire lui-même que
la situation de 2010 c'est tout un
peuple et à la même époque pour tous car
nous a conviés il était sûr de son
talent était entre le fc 10 et il a fini
à dix neuf voire frôlant pratiquement à
la qualification second plan est ce que
aujourd'hui il est en mesure de réaliser
à nouveau ce parcours était par contre
quand même extrêmement important sur le
plan de l'efficacité électorale c'est
difficile de lire parce que lui aussi
appelé les conditions d'un désunion à
gauche le
lilas un quinquennat notre guide et qui
était un quinquennat qui essaient de
coups d'éclat de rupture de
conflictuelle it et toutes ces deux
traits de caractère parfois peuvent en
laisse et irrité un certain nombre de
ses partenaires quand bien même jean luc
mélenchon dispose d'un talent évident
charisme que contestable la primaire
populaire le dépense wild arms qui a été
montée contre jean luc mélenchon c'est
en tout cas en effet ils ont un
dispositif qui me semble t'il eu regard
de ce qu'on voit de la scène politique à
gauche semblent on peut pas rajouter de
la division à la division est loin de
clarifier les choses tant tour les
obscurs merci beaucoup à arnaud
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire